wir sind unterwegs in der Hafenstadt
Ranja einem beliebten Urlaubsort auf
Kreta seit Jahren auch beliebt bei
kinderlosen Paaren die sich ihren
sehnlichsten Wunsch erfüllen wollen denn
hier blüht das Geschäft mit leimüttern
aus Ländern wie Georgien und
Rumänien wir dachten dass Griechenland
ein sicherer Ort sei an den man gehen
könne aber das wurde hier leider
ausgenutzt es gibt auch das Gerücht dass
es eine Art Mafia rund um die
reproduktionsklinik gibt
die Frauen haben nicht mal im
Krankenhaus auf die Ärzte und Schwestern
reagiert sie haben immer gesagt sprechen
Sie mit meinem
Boss im August wurden der 73-Jährige
Chef einer reproduktionsklinik und
sieben mutmaßliche Beteiligte verhaftet
seine Klinik soll im Zentrum einer
kriminellen Vereinigung stehen die
Anklage unter anderem Menschenhandel und
Ausbeutung von Frauen als leimütter in
mindestens 98 Fällen mindestens 13 Mal
sollen dafür Dokumente gefälscht und 71
mal Frauen als eizellspenderinnen
missbraucht worden
sein wir sind nach Kreta gereist um
betroffene Frauen zu finden und zu
verstehen wie so etwas mitten in Europa
passieren
[Musik]
kann Griechenland ist das einzige Land
in der EU in der leimutterschaft sogar
für wunscheltern und leimütter aus dem
Ausland erlaubt ist laut Gesetz darf
eine Frau das Baby für andere zwar nur
aus nächsten Liebe austragen doch eine
Aufwandsentschädigung ist erlaubt von
immerhin 15 000 €. für die Frauen aus
Ländern wie Georgien und Rumänien ist
das viel Geld wurde also ihre Not
ausgenutzt ein Millionengeschäft gemacht
auf dem Rücken der leimütter heute
sollen vor Gericht drei leimütter als
Zeuginnen gehört werden vor der Tür
kommen wir mit dem Ehemann einer
Angeklagten ins Gespräch die sich um die
leimütter gekümmert hatte er regt sich
über den Begriff menshandel auf der
Klinge als ob man die Frauen gekidnappt
hätte dabei seien sie freiwillig
gekommen um Geld zu verdienen weil die
Regierung sich nicht kümmere würde er
das jetzt tun und hätte aus eigener
Tasche eine Villa mit Pool angemietet
was davon stimmt an die leimütter kommen
wir hier nicht dran sie sind gut
beschützt nach wochenlanger Suche
erhalten wir den Kontakt zu einer
leimutter die mit uns reden will die
Georgierin hat bereits vor ein paar
Monaten entbunden und ist zurück in
ihrer Heimat aus Angst will sie anonym
bleiben das schlimmste war die
kontrollierende Umgebung du konntest
keine neuen Leute
kennenlernen oder Freunde auf Besuch
[Musik]
empfangen sogar Familienmitglieder oder
der eigene Ehemann oder die Mutter
durften nicht zu Besuch
kommen ich sollte von allen
abgeschnitten werden ich habe mich
einsam gefühlt und nicht
[Musik]
frei Eleni deren Namen wir geändert
haben erzählt dass sie sich auf eine
Anzeige im Internet gemeldet hatte die
geschiedene Mutter von zwei Kindern
brauchte dringend Geld nach einer kurzen
Untersuchung wurde sie gemeinsam mit
zwei anderen Frauen nach Kreta gebracht
die Aufwandsentschädigung von 15 000 €
die sie erhalten hat ist nach
griechischem Gesetz erlaubt verboten
sind lediglich die Werbung für die
leimutterschaft im Ausland und der
Transport der Frauen insland Elen
erzählt von der Georgierin die sie und
die anderen Frauen aus der Ferne
überwacht
habe sie kennt all diese Mädchen und hat
sie in WhatsApp und schreibt ständig und
ruft an und manchmal redet ein Mädchen
über ein anderes schlechte Dinge und das
mag sie weil sie kontrollieren kann auf
diese Art und Weise kann sie alle
Mädchen
kontrollieren während Paradies neue
touristenrekorde verzeichnet verkaufen
wenige Meter weiter Frauen ihre Freiheit
kaum vorstellbar dass niemand davon
etwas mitbekommen haben will wir wollen
Details erfahren und sind mit der
Journalistin Katharina poisu aus Chan
verabredet die seit Wochen intensiv an
dem Skandal recherchiert sie erzählt von
der Mauer des Schweigens die ihr
entgegengebracht wird die Griechinnen
und Griechen hätten Angst als
Denunzianten zu
gelten das ist nicht leicht weil wir in
einer kleinen Gemeinschaft von Menschen
leben die Festgenommenen waren sehr
bekannt in Hanan sie hatten viele
Freunde manche Leute können nicht
glauben dass so etwas passiert und sie
haben auch Angst zu
reden offenbar hätten die leimütter aus
Georgien Rumänien und Bulgarien
jahrelang mitten in der Stadt gelebt
ohne mit jemandem zu reden erzählt sie
beim Einkaufen seien sie nicht
aufgefallen wohl aber im
Krankenhaus die meisten sprechen
überhaupt kein Englisch oder griechisch
ich weiß dass sie im Krankenhaus nicht
mal den Ärzten und Schwestern
geantwortet hatten sie meinten immer nur
sprechen Sie mit unserem
Boss Katharina will uns zeigen wie die
Frauen gelebt haben sie gibt uns
Adressen von normalen Wohnhäusern die
über die ganze Stadt verteilt sind wir
wollen wissen ob sich dort immer noch
leimütter aufhalten und fahren nur 5 K
weiter das Haus sieht bewohnt aus eine
Spur aus schwarzen kohlezeichen führt zu
einer
[Musik]
Wohnung was uns erwartet wissen wir
nicht mit einer handyapp haben wir uns
auf verschiedene Sprachen vorbereitet es
klopft zurück ein
geheimsignal
hallo
hallo hallo sind sie die georgische Frau
die hier lebt ja kann ich Ihnen was auf
Georgisch zeigen eine
Übersetzung sie
rein eine ganz normale Wohnung die
georgische Frau erzählt dass sie vor
kurzem entbunden hat und bald zurück in
ihre Heimat will über die Organisation
und ihre Mitbewohnerinnen hier sie
nichts
erzählen im staatlichen Krankenhaus das
jetzt die leimütter betreut können wir
einen Informanten sprechen acht Babys
seien seit August hier geboren worden
zwei von ihnen konnten noch nicht
abgeholt werden erzählt er denn
vermutlich sein Papiere gefälscht und
möglicherweise sogar Eizellen vertauscht
worden das würde gerade
geprüft viele der wunscheltern erfahren
wir sind aus Australien vermittelt von
einer Agentur 70 bis 100.000 € haben sie
für das Versprechen bezahlt endlich ein
eigenes Baby zu bekommen der Chef der
Agentur Sam avham spricht von 100
leimüttern die noch schwanger sein
sollen seit den Verhaftungen sei das
System der leimutterschaft
zusammengebrochen das Problem ist einige
dieser leimütter sind in ihre
Heimatländer geflohen und die
wunscheltern können ihre leimütter
möglicherweise nicht finden wir wissen
nicht mal ob sie noch schwanger sind
oder nicht und was sagt die Klinik dazu
auf unsere Fragen bekommen wir nicht mal
eine Reaktion der leimutterskandal von
Kreta ist noch lange nicht aufgeklärt
das Ermittlungsverfahren in Chan soll
jetzt Licht in die Angelegenheit bringen
doch solange das weltweite Geschäft mit
wunschbabys so lukrativ ist und die
Gesetzeslage in Griechenland so
schwammig bleibt kann sich dieser
Skandal jederzeit
wiederholen
ه